I want to start with congrats I've
watched the episodes
um I think fans are really going to dig
it
um how have you actually been telling
your friends and family about the show
in terms of who you play and what you
get to do well I
I've been talking about Syndrome from
standpoint of our our two characters
being siblings Celestial twins yeah
um born under the same star sharing a
similar type of magic that's very
Earthbound and nature related
um
and kind of uh trying to keep things
under wraps but I guess the main bulk of
it is this group of seven anti-heroes
that that are from different walks of
life and different Traditions that band
together for a common purpose of
defeating this evil that lies in in
Centralia
um so that's the main that's what I've
mainly been telling people and then you
know saying that every now and again I
get to give a spell we get to do some
magic you can see some pretty fun magic
absolutely I want to do a follow-up on
that how much fun is it for you guys
um it must be like you're five years old
again when you're pretending to do magic
how much fun is it for both of you when
you get to do those scenes it's it's
really really fun and I think I think
what we kind of what I certainly
discovered uh during the process of
shooting the show is how much a sense of
kind of imagination and play is really
really necessary to this genre into this
world particularly when you're working
with sort of special effects and CGI and
and a lot of what you're bringing to any
given moment is maybe not perhaps
materially in front of you but it's all
alive and Vivid in your imagination I
think and we're speaking about kind of
what we learned from working with some
many of the Fantastic actors on this
show and learning from Lenny Henry for
example he bought a real sense of kind
of play and fun and experimentation and
to to the set which I I think I sort of
really am fed off and I really it really
liberated me to be able to feel like I
was able to reconnect with that sort of
inner child
um that you know makes up makes up games
in the playground at school and I think
it's it's a really important part of
what we do when we engage with the world
of fantasy which is what's so beautiful
about it and that note I already have to
stop I'm just gonna say [ __ ] it so it
goes really quick
um you guys congrats on the show and I
wish you nothing but the best thank you
so much thank you